you have another project you have many
that you're doing with Jim another
projects a web series yes it's called
legendary and I'm set to shoot in the
fall but this this is another one of
those opportunities coming through and
being open to it I got an email a few
months back on facebook from a young
writer director named Jay Lee and he's
based out of Portland Oregon and he
originally emailed me about an animated
web series he was doing that he was
looking for voice-over characters for
you know so as I can yeah wait a couple
days then I was like you as a side
project like what's the deal or you know
are you offering pay oh you know who are
you um and so he sent me a link and I
checked it on and I was like well this
was actually really decent quality stuff
for animated voice over some guy in
Portland and like okay and so we're
chatting a little bit and he said he was
a fan of robot chicken and that's how he
knew who I was I said okay well then
turns out he has to come to town a
couple weeks later for a convention that
he was at and I had a hosting gig I was
hosting a rock and roll show over at the
Hard Rock Cafe and so him and his buddy
came down and so I got the chat with
them well then the truth comes out and
so apparently he's been a fan since
Deadwood and lank he's been a fan for i
guess like six seven years now in life
so you've been stalking me all this try
right but and it's still such a new
strange thing to me to find out like you
know there's somebody's been following
my work and been a fan of my work you
know for a couple projects now and so
now the truth comes out that what he's
really got going on its legendary and
it's a game of thrones as type web
series that's shooting up in Portland
they've already begun they've already
started shooting with teasers and the
trailers and the really super awesome
cool thing about this is that he
recently went to a panel in missouri and
george RR martin was on the panel with
him and so j got to show him and tell
him about the project and George loved
it and he totally endorse did they got
him on camera and so if you look at
their they have a little trailer on
their website right now and they've got
other footage they haven't shown yet but
they've got footage of george RR martin
talking about how great legendary is and
he makes some sort of joke like I mean
it's very game of thrones disc in like
you know it's like a tale of you know
blood and steel or something you know
and Game of Thrones it's like a tale of
iron and Fire vice versa you know and so
george RR martin makes a joke on the
video he goes you know ice and fire i
like that blood and steel is a better
run to it but you know and so it's a
funny thing because I could see had he
not got the endorsement of George first
when this web series comes out people
can be like Allen so much like Game of
Thrones you know but benefit yet but you
know what the master just said like
thumbs up and I like this idea nobody's
doing anything like this and the photos
are gorgeous like the locations but
they're shooting at there's this one
photo that he just put up where he's
directing one of the actresses into a
waterfall and she's like standing by the
waterfall and that this is the land
they're shooting on they have like a
castle that they're going to be allowed
to use and so two of my girlfriend's
have actually been booked on the project
as well Helena Santos sleepy and
Stephanie Thorpe Stephanie will be
speaking on the comic-con panel with me
and Helen I have been friends of a very
long time and we've spoken on panels
together with the geek girls create
panels and so all three of us are cast
and we're going to be shooting this fall
and you know I mean for a low-budget web
series I mean they're flying us up
they've got flights accommodations for
damn salary it's sag it's you know it's
the whole nine yards and it's and it's
somebody who's not even in Los Angeles
which is which opened up my eyes back to
like Lucas McNelly and is a year without
rent and my experience with the game
we're guys in Philly is that there's a
lot of stuff going on not just LA and
what I'm starting to find is that
filmmakers from other cities and states
are now reaching out to me because here
I am a Los Angeles actress and I am a
SAG actress and I do have a little bit
of following in some credits but I am
totally open to go be in anyone's
project anywhere you know what I mean
like and I support that kind of thing so
he's only a little bit about my
character her name is on aura and he
basically said there was a mayor of the
town she would be it which i think is
kind of interesting because they're you
know females in that era really didn't
have and she's not royalty though her
father was a great warrior and he's
known I don't have all the names of my
head but he's known for defeating this
like humongous monstrous creature and
that's like what he's known for and her
mother was you know a seamstress in the
town like a very good seamstress that
actually helped create like the initial
code on the badges of these warriors and
so I'm assuming that both my parents
have now passed away and i own a lot of
properties one in particular being like
the local pub and as such i get all the
like travelers that come through and all
the dirt licks and all the bad seeds and
everybody that comes through but i also
get to hear over here lots of
conversations to help you know the good
guys and so what's being planned or
who's traveling through our town so i
don't know it's just I can't wait i'm
really excited it's so the by the time
this airs the websites going up and
because this this hasn't actually been
announced but by the time this airs this
will be announced in the cast updates
will be announced and press releases are
going out and i just know that we're all
really excited to shoot this
you